Speaker 1: Regardless of whether you believe
vaccines work, which they do, or whether COVID is
likely to be serious in any particular population
about which we have different data, like
regardless of all of those disagreements that some
people have not using fact to come to conclusions,
most everybody would agree. If you have COVID,
you should stay home right like you. Even people
who don't want to get vaccinated mostly believe
COVID exists. It's contagious, and you should
stay home when you have COVID. Former Republican
Congresswoman Michele Bachmann is now praising
Sarah Palin for going out to restaurants when
she was contagious and infected with COVID
last week. So we're going to look at that. Just
as a reminder, Sarah Palin was seen dining at a
Manhattan restaurant, Leo's Italian restaurant in
the Upper East Side. She had COVID at the time.
You may remember that the timeline was. And now
I want to make sure I have the timeline right?
She tested positive for COVID. I believe it was
January 23rd. Sunday, the 23rd. She had been out
to eat in New York on Saturday, the 22nd, and then
she was seen within the five day period during
which you're not supposed to be out. She was seen
in the middle of last week on Wednesday outdoor
dining at restaurants. We actually had that clip
for you last week. We're just going to take a look
at a little bit of it here with with no audio.
I'll describe what we're seeing. You see Sarah
Palin sitting at a restaurant, one of these like
indoor outdoor, outdoor indoor type scenarios.
This also raised the question This technically
is outside. But a few days earlier, she had
reportedly been indoors at this restaurant, and
New York does require proof of vaccination to
dine indoors. The question is, is she actually
vaccinated? But she's been lying that she's not
ordered the restaurant. Just not check for
the vaccination. OK, whatever the case may be.
So Michelle Bachmann is interviewed on Fox News,
and she says we should be commending Sarah Palin
for being out with COVID. That's what she said.
Speaker 2: Take a look as different reactions
to it. But I think honestly, Sarah Palin
is to be commended because she's trying
to act like a normal human being in the
greatest city in America, New York City.
She's going out to eat at a wonderful little
boutique Italian restaurant as different react.
Speaker 1: So that's the view. She
should be commended for it now. I wonder,
like prior to COVID, right? When during
flu season, if Michele Bachmann found out.
That a Republican was out with the flu eating
at restaurants, would they say that's a great
heroic thing to do? While we should, we
should really commend her for being out
with the flu. That's a really great thing. This
is getting more and more stupid every day. And
I don't think it's going to turn around
soon. Some people said, Well, this is
Darwinism at its finest. It's really not because
Darwinism would be that this behavior kills off
Palin before she's able to reproduce. She's
got kids already. So unfortunately, it's not
Darwinism. It might just spread the virus to other
people at the restaurant who did nothing wrong.
But now, I mean, it's gotten so backwards
that they are now cheering people who go out
with a highly contagious virus to restaurants.
That's the rock bottom that we have now hit.